this is Cora pica now he's a scary
little fellow who has just struck you
with his nen ability known as judgment
chain allowing him to issue you with a
command and he's going to give you a
very simple request here which is that
if you haven't already please do
subscribe to the new ultra view for
regular hunt onto content upload it
straight into your YouTube feed and if
you don't well then Crocker will punish
you with a mild sense of heartburn for
the remainder of your days choose wisely
hello and welcome to the new world
review your source for everything anime
and manga and today it's time to examine
the glorious vault of nen users once
more because hunter hunter is full of
incredible specimens now just quickly
before we begin I do want to emphasize
that this is a sequel video and there is
an original top 5 best nen users list on
this channel a link to which will be in
the description below and I point that
out because if an end user that you love
is not here today and I would recommend
checking on that list first because
chances are they have a home there but
as for some criteria regarding what
makes a best ninh user well that simply
means an individual who has excelled in
their particular practice of nen in
whatever field that just so happens to
be so very notably this does not
necessarily mean the strongest or most
powerful men users biggest strengths in
combat is only one facet of this wide
wide world and we are expanding our gaze
to seek excellence and world-class usage
in general and I think that that
criteria will become very clear as we
move forward so with that out of the way
let's begin welcome to another edition
of the top 5 best nen users in Hunter
hunter number 5 Razer kicking things off
we have everyone's favorite dodge ball
enthusiast index criminal turned game
master and razor is a surprisingly
undisputed force in this world
displaying a clear dominance in terms of
nen during the greed island arc
requiring a combination of gone killer
he soaked abyss key and many many others
just to defeat him within the bounds of
a simple dodgeball match so looking at
raw power alone you can certainly make
the argument that Razer belongs here but
the funny thing is that isn't even his
greatest selling feature as a natural
emitter and Game Master of Great Island
Razer is personally responsible for
every mechanic within the game that
requires emission usage and that
requires him to invest his aura into
thousands upon thousands of cons and as
such it is raises personal aura that
keeps this game going which is a
staggering fact because everything we
saw of him in the dodgeball match
theoretically only represents a fraction
of his aura reserves
considering so much of it was invested
simply into keeping greed Island run
and yet with all of that in mind he
still has enough clout to imitate the
large majority of the Phantom troop as
well as comfortably engage in his 14
Devils answers which is a nice creative
summoning of Nan beasts that go to serve
races greater purpose in life that
purpose being deadly dodgeball however
with that said razor is quite possibly
one of the greatest slept on nan masters
in this world hidden away on greed
Island flying under the radar and it
really does make you wonder how many
more beings like this could exist in
hunter hunter but for now razor is well
and truly a force deserving of our
opening spot number four never Peto next
up we have simultaneously one of the
most adorable yet sinister beings ever
introduced in let's say oh love media
and in addition to that we also have a
particularly dynamic specialist user of
nen now in many ways Peto was gifted
their excellence and then being born
into the role of oral God and having
effectively unlimited quantities of aura
at their disposal but where Peter really
shines in comparison to the rest of the
Royal Guards is how they put that to use
going on to develop an incredible array
of heart - to suit very specific needs
and yet having the versatility to apply
them to more desperate situations like
for example one of the moments burned
into my mind is when Pete oh invoke
doctor Blythe to stop themselves midair
after being struck by network despite
the fact that doctor Blythe was an
ability designed exclusively for healing
and reconstruction the Peter also
managed to create a whole host of
absurdly puppet based abilities to the
point where they even crafted a method
by which to puppeteer themselves which
can be seen in the terpsichore Tohatsu
in which an end ballerina takes control
of Peto and forces their body to move
beyond its natural limitations so it's a
very creative way to effectively achieve
some sort of power although it does come
at a great physical cost to its user but
when discussing tubs korra we also need
to bring up the Peto is one of the rare
individuals in the series to engage in
post-mortem nen as even after their
death terpsichore continued to persist
manipulating Peters corpse and even
claiming one of our old Kong's arms so
Pete Doe is yeah pretty wildly powerful
in regards to nen but Vito is also
another rare being whose outer dominance
in the art form can be seen in its very
basic applications and probably the best
example of this is Vito Zen which can
reach further than any known master the
world where of and can remain active for
days on end so for some comparison Zeno
zoldak has famously stated that he could
release an n with a 300 meter radius
although it would be a tiring technique
to invoke whereas Vito can create an n
that is
more than six times that radius and
never have any fear of tiring and in
addition to that Peters end can also
change shape giving it ridiculous
amounts of versatility at that to the
fact that Peter can seemingly create
whatever hearts who they want on a whim
and you have easily one of the most
dangerous yet superbly talented men
users in all of on Toronto
number three Kannagi now here's one that
may surprise a lot of you as she is
quite possibly the physically weakest
character ever introduced in haunt
hunter but an undeniable force in one
particular area that being the game of
gungi now very notably Kaimuki is
unaware that she is using net she is an
example of one of those unconscious
athlete types who has invoked their aura
naturally through whatever mechanism
which in comedy's case is more than
likely her profound belief that she can
do nothing else in life but to play
gunky as a result Kaimuki has even put a
very dangerous condition on her nen
usage which is that if she were to ever
lose a game of gungi she would die once
again I have to stress that Kaimuki did
not implement this with any technical
understanding of what she was doing it
was pure desire and it has given her
unparalleled power to rapidly respond
incorporate and innovate and in the
stream of gungi strategy far beyond the
mental capabilities of any human but not
only that her mental prowess in this
specific area was even above that of the
most terrifyingly intelligent character
in the series being the Chimera and King
marijuana marijuana despite obliterating
champions of other games was never able
to overcome kimochi her unconscious use
of nen only ever fed off the stimuli
provided by marijuana and on each and
every occasion it rose to topple the
king and if you think about it in one
way kimochi is the only character in the
series who was ever able to convincingly
defeat Mero M in any way shape or form
and that certainly makes her one of the
best known users in the series whether
she realizes it or not
number two karappa Co yeah it's quite
possibly one of my greatest shame as
Karaka most certainly should have been
on the original list but we're here to
make up for that today kropog a-- is one
of the most creative efficient and most
wildly powerful nen users to have ever
existed and he became that way in a
comparatively miniscule amount of time
compared to that of the great nen
masters of Hunter hunter and a lot of
this is the result of kropog a-- having
a very clear goal in mind his sole
mission in life is to retrieve the eyes
of the members of the Goethe clan as
well as take revenge on those
to perform their massacre at being
fountain true in this drive and clarity
has led Cora pika down there very clear
but dangerous path developing a very
particular set of skills many of which
are designed to have a compound effect
on each other so for example the basis
of crop occurs nin supremacy is a hot -
known as Emperor time which he can only
activate as a specialist because also
tropica is the early known character in
the world who can switch between two
different affinities being conjuration
and specialization but Emperor time then
goes on to allow him to maximize have
free oven an affinity making it nyeon
impossible for an opponent to identify
what affinity kropog actually is much
less being able to deal with the so of
potent techniques that he can unleash
and the prime example I have of this
would be change ale which combined with
judgment chain allow Karaka to set a
condition for himself which is to only
use change ale on members of the phantom
truth well Korra pika will be instantly
killed as a result though members of the
troupe have no defense against this
ability even the more monstrous one such
as ooh virgeen but one often forgotten
about factor is that every other one of
crop ACCA's techniques are free of this
restriction and furthermore kropog has
the acute mentality to put them to use
on a world-class scale and just to take
another example briefly let's look at
dowsing chain which is pretty much
designed to be a long-range attack
it's a classic Bolin chain right to the
no can of any enemy the Karaka is just
so damn proficient in regards to nen
that he even figured out how to put this
technique to use as a lie detector which
not only works in real life it can also
be used through video footage and
honestly this brief explanation does not
even begin to scratch the surface of
what crop occur is capable of and it
only gets more and more insane as we
perceived with the current arc in the
manga although it should be said that he
does certainly pay the price for this as
every second spent active in Emperor
time removes one hour of his or her full
lifespan but in doing so it allows him
to become one of the most formidable
presences within this entire series and
in closing once again nothing I can say
in this short amount of time can even
come close to doing crop good justice in
this discussion he has a clear Drive
leading to powerful high-risk
high-reward abilities and a natural mind
for mitigating the risk portion of that
statement so Korra paga is a profoundly
amazing nen user but with everything
I've just said it is still pretty hard
to deny number one
Jing freaks ending this exploration we
have someone that I did bring up as a
candidate last time but ultimately I
could not bring myself to include him
largely due to a lack of evidence
regarding his abilities and they usage
for this time around things are a bit
different because we can no longer
dismiss the information that we do have
and the thing about Jing is that he very
much owns his place here through
prestige alone Jing is a highly
respected member of the hunter
Association having risen to the rank of
a double star hunter and look if he
wasn't so lazy he could have even been a
triple star hunter as well and despite
how widely disliked he is by the
Association at large he was still able
to earn a spot as a member of the
zodiacs but the piece of information
that people will most often bring up is
a statement from Chairman net or himself
who claimed that Jing was one of the top
five best men users in the world which
is you know word for word what I'm
proposing to explore in this list so by
word of mouth alone he does technically
belong here however we do have some
delicious morsels of actual evidence to
examine as well the first of which is
simply that Jing is an absurdly talented
nen monster that with a solid enough
understanding of a particular ability
Jing is generally able to replicate said
ability which was demonstrated in
regards to lair areas ultrasound and
remote pond charts ooh and I just like
to note that copying abilities is not
genes personal hearts ooh it is just
achieved through raw talent which is
kind of mind-boggling given everything
we know about how difficult it is to
implement an ant on even the most basic
of levels what's also interesting to
think about is that we do not know
Jing's natural nin affinity which could
go towards explaining a lot of what he
was if that was say especial esteem if
like his son he is a natural enhancer
and that only makes his mastery of this
art form that much more impressive but
for some more tangible evidence we can
also look at his skill in the art of pit
play the game in which one moves there
or are about to perform some fun and
fancy tricks so you could consider it
like an N form of Cantus tree or even
gloving and does anyone actually
remember gloving feel like it's
definitely a bit of a relic of the past
at this stage it back to something I
guess mildly more relevant Jing skill in
pit play was enough to astound even a
self-proclaimed master of the game so
that's surely saying something but with
all this in mind it is very very
difficult to deny that Jing as he has
quite literally been stated to be is one
of the top five best known users in the
series and certainly does deserve his
crown here today but what do you guys
think please leave your thoughts in the
comments below or even join my discord
server and if you're keen for some more
Hunter hunter content and please do
check out some of my
videos and even subscribe to the channel
for regular hunt hunter glory delivered
straight to your YouTube feed but for
now this has been the new old review and
I'll see you next time